last month tracy ellis ross teamed up
she got gorgeous here teamed up with
beauty retail giant
ulta to be its new diversity and
inclusion advisor
tracy ellis ross good morning as if you
don't have enough to do but i think
ulta's got very good sense
recruiting you to do this job there's
nobody better
thank you good morning gail good morning
you all how are you
well we all be good this morning let's
talk about pattern for just a second
number one it's got great packaging
i used it over the weekend because
you've got the leave-in conditioner
you've got the intensive condenser so i
feel really good sitting here talking to
you today
but you talked about when you started
this hair care line it was your own
personal journey
what do you mean by that um well
like so many black women i could
chronicle my journey of self-acceptance
through my journey with my hair
and um society's standards of beauty
didn't include or celebrate the
authenticity of my hair or the magnitude
of its importance or its legacy
and as i went through my hair journey i
noticed and saw so many missing
things in the market um and it was a
10-year journey for me
birthing this company it took 10 years
to get it off the ground
and by the time i did get it off the
ground i had sort of a bible of what
all of the things that i wanted the
company to answer um
and i wanted pattern to be an access
point for people where they could
um you know celebrate and be their most
beautiful self in their own bathroom
yeah
mission it's so good to feel that's
funny
to feel beautiful in your own bathroom
with just you yourself
and you i know that you have a good
feeling
but usually gail you know it's like we
think there's a professional that has to
give us our beauty
and i disagree i think that you can have
access to your most beautiful self
in your own bathroom i still need a
professional thank you giselle
i still need me a professional but you
said that the pandemic has reinvigorated
you
has reinvigorated your business how so
and your mission
well the the mission of the company um
is to
meet the needs of the curly coily and
tight textured community and we're an
active space
that is centered around the celebration
of black beauty um
loving and uplifting our humanity and
where were the subjects and not the
the objects of our content and we've
noticed in covid and the racial
reckoning
has laid so much bear and we noticed how
we care for ourselves is so important
in how we maintain our selfhood and not
much else exists
so self-care is an act of self-love and
um i also think that hair is a portal to
our souls and that it connects us to our
legacy
and our ancestors and our identity and
so the act of caring for
our hair is essential in honoring our
existence and our dignity and our
humanity and as a company
that's what we do you know we we will
continue and and the the pandemic sort
of
reinvigorated the mission and it it we
get back to serving supporting and
loving the community and honoring and
celebrating and lifting us up got it
tracy it's anthony i want to talk about
one of your other careers at the moment
acting but in 2017 you won a golden
globe for
for best actress in a comedy and you
were the at the time you were the first
black actress
uh to win that award since 1983
what do you make of of what's going on
with the hollywood foreign press
association and the revelation
that among their 80-something members
there's not a single
black member well i think
that no black members is a symptom
of a problem and not the problem itself
and i think with power comes a lot of
responsibility
and the hfpa has a lot of power and i
feel like
um we are in a time
in this country where so many of the
systems of oppression
have infiltrated all industries and i
think the hfpa
is no exception and it is time for
change and we all need to
and i don't think it's about cosmetic
change i think it's about fundamental
change
and that requires a lot of
accountability and responsibility
and um change you know these hidden
power structures
and toxic cultures uh need to go were
you satisfied with the statement they
made last night which was basically that
we know we have to change
i don't think statements are anything i
think action is everything
and i think um i think fundamental
change requires a real
um self-awareness and really taking a
look and again no black members is a
symptom
of the problem it's not the problem
itself it's like every every moms always
says action speaks louder than words
let's talk about girlfriends it's a big
anniversary for girlfriends and now it's
streaming on netflix
what's that like for you to watch it
again or do you watch it again
i did watch it i've watched some of it i
i went in and i went out
um it's fascinating i'm so amazed at how
we hold up over
how the the time matter um the stories
that we were telling
really still feel so relevant um
i mean but look how young and and tight
and thin
guess what transient you're still young
and tight and thin
it could go either what two ways either
you cringe and go or you say hey i look
pretty good
you can say the latter you look pretty
good and you still do tracey ellis
thank you cheering you on give yourself
a round of applause always good to see
have a great day you guys you too our
women's history month coverage continues
tomorrow only on cbs this morning
we're going to talk to the soccer star
there she is abby wambach and her wife
new york times
best-selling author glennon doyle